>> Tucker: LIKE PRISONERS
PUTTING CHECKS ON A CONCRETE
WALL, WE LIKE TO MARK THE
PASSAGE OF TIME ON THE SHOW.
AS OF TODAY, ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION TO RUSSIA HAS BEEN
RUNNING FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED?
JOE DEGENEVA JOINS US WITH A
RECAP.
JOE, WHAT DO WE KNOW?
>> WE KNOW THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WAS ILLEGALLY EXONERATED, WE
KNEW THAT ONE YEAR AGO.
WE KNEW THERE WAS A SUBSTANTIAL
EFFORT TO FRAME THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WITH CRIMES BY INFILTRATING HIS
CAMPAIGN, AND THEN HIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH SPIES THAT
THE FBI HAD SET UP ON THEM.
WE LEARNED THAT THE CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED BY THE FBI, SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, MR. CLAPPER, MR. COMEY,
AND OTHERS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS ASSOCIATES
COMMITTED NO CRIMES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S QUITE A
LITANY.
SO TO THE SPYING QUESTION, THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED THAT MORNING,
I WILL NEVER FORGET IT, THEY
SPIED ON US FROM TRUMP TOWER.
I DON'T THINK THERE WAS A SINGLE
PERSON THAT DIDN'T THINK, THAT'S
A HEAVY DUTY CHARGE, CAN YOU
PROVE IT?
THAT HAS IN EFFECT BEEN APPROVED
THAT HAS IN EFFECT BEEN APPROVE
APPROVED.
>> JOE: ABSOLUTELY.
THE FBI PROVE THAT IN ALL
GUIDELINES AND ALL ESCALATION,
AND I BELIEVE THEY COMMITTED
CRIMES IN DOING SO, PURPOSELY
SENT PEOPLE INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TO PLANT FALSE
INFORMATION, THEN FORCE THAT
INFORMATION TO BE FORWARDED BACK
TO THE CIA AND FUNNELED TO THE
FBI TO BE USED AS FALSE
INFORMATION IN PFIZER
APPLICATIONS.
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THAT
PROCESS WHO KNOWINGLY
PARTICIPATED COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> Tucker: SO WHY ARE THEY NOT
BEING HELD TO ACCOUNT?
>> JOE: AS OF TODAY I BELIEVE
THAT A REFERRAL FOR PROSECUTION
HAS BEEN MADE TO MR. HUBER WHO
IS INVESTIGATING THE LEAKS, AND
EVERYTHING THAT WE DESCRIBE
TONIGHT.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN MADE AND I SUGGEST THAT
MR. BRENNAN, WHO LOVES TO MAKE
COMMENT ABOUT THE PROCESS GET
HIMSELF A GOOD LAWYER, NOT A
GOOD WRITER.
>> Tucker: WAIT, JOHN BRENNAN,
THE NBC NEWS PAID CONSULTANT?
>> JOE: YES, THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTRAL
INTELLIGENCE 80 AND SEE, THE
MOST PARTISAN HACK WHO NEEDS A
VERY, VERY GOOD LAWYER.
>> Tucker: A CRIMINAL LAWYER.
>> JOE: YES.
HE DOESN'T NEED A SLIP AND FALL
LAWYER, ALTHOUGH HE MAY SLIP AND
FALL.
HE WILL BE IN FRONT OF A GRAND
JURY SHORTLY.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT'S NEWS.
>> JOE: YES, AND IT'S GOOD
NEWS.
>> Tucker: THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE TIME THAT YOU HAVE COME
ON THAT I DON'T FEEL BETTER AT